the President of the United States is
accusing sections of his own government
of attempting a coup on Tuesday Donald
Trump tweeted I am coming to the
conclusion that what is taking place is
not an impeachment it is a coup intended
to take away the power of the people
their vote their freedoms the late-night
tweet from the White House came after
reports emerged that yet another
government watchdog has agreed to meet
with Congress Steve linic the State
Department Inspector General will
reportedly deliver an urgent briefing on
Wednesday even as the head of his agency
secretary of state Mike Pompeo said the
testimony of State Department employees
was not feasible
Pompeyo a staunch Trump ally also
accused Democrats of intimidating
witnesses in their fast-paced
impeachment probe while Democrats
accused Pompeo of the same but a Senate
trial itself would be incredibly
damaging to President Trump because it
would lay out for the American people in
great detail all of the charges and all
of the evidence against him and would
put the President on the defensive and
he would have to answer the charges with
real arguments and real analysis not
with talking about cooze and civil wars
and spies to former state employees will
testify to Congress behind closed doors
the Ukrainian envoy who resigned last
week will give his deposition on
Thursday the former US ambassador to
Ukraine will have her turn October 11th
both are mentioned in a whistleblower
complaint that President Trump leveraged
US diplomacy to pressure ukrainian
President Vladimir's elinsky to
investigate Trump's domestic political
rivals szalinski denied the allegation
on Tuesday Nicolas nitcholas or north
blue I've never felt any influence on me
and there are a lot of people in Russia
in the West and in Ukraine who would
like to influence me but I'm the
president of Ukraine of independent
Ukraine and it seems to me that my steps
so far show that it is impossible to
influence me President Trump says the
Ukrainian investigation is
folks he has repeatedly tried to
discredit the whistleblower an
intelligence officer who remains
anonymous Trump has said on Twitter that
he wants to find out the officers
identity even as a senior member of his
own Republican Party says the
whistleblower ought to be heard and
protected heidi Joe Castro al Jazeera
Washington